- We need to be more 80/20,
the team is not working 80/20 enough.
You need to approach this
analysis with the 80/20 mentality.
So the 80/20 Principle or the 80/20 Rule
or the Pareto Principle, as
some people are calling it,
this is the topic for today's video.
This principle or rule is so commonplace
in consulting and in many
other industries as well
that this term is almost a cliche.
So as important as it is,
I want you to really
understand what it's all about,
why it's used so frequently in consulting
and what indeed the value of it all is.
So let me start you by explaining
what this is all about.
And indeed this Pareto Principle
how it was originally called
was invented by Vilfredo Pareto.
He was an Italian economist,
and he apparently found out
that in Italy at the time 80% of the land
was owned by 20% of the people.
So, 80/20, this relationship,
this is what it's all about.
And this now permutes
in lots of other areas
of society, of work.
And indeed the common
implication here for work
is that often for many many tasks,
80% of the results
are created by 20% of
the activities, 80/20.
So this is the topic that we
are going to talk about today.
So, welcome to Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich Rusche
on my channel Firm Learning.
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
I'm a former McKinsey
Management Consultant.
And on my channel, I try to share my tips
both for soft skills and hard skills
that you need to be successful.
So if you wanna hear more about that,
feel free to subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
So indeed today's topic
is the Pareto Principle.
I will look at it for two directions.
The first is actually
the application of it
in analysis that you do,
in practical work,
in your work as a consultant.
So how can you leverage this principle
to use it for work that you
do together with the client?
But then second,
I'm also going to talk about
how it's often used internally.
So, let's dig into it to better understand
how the Pareto Principle really works.
And what you see here is the typical curve
of how such a Pareto
relationship really looks like.
And indeed the
characteristic of this curve
is that in the beginning,
the curve has a very high slope
that then reduces over time,
goes down over time and
less it's almost zero
in the very end.
But what do you actually see here?
So on the x-axis
you see the different elements,
the different items, components,
that then create a certain effect.
And these components are
ordered by their size,
or magnitude or impact, right?
So the first components are the strongest,
biggest, best ones.
And then the magnitude goes down.
And then on the y-axis
you see the effect, the output,
the outcome of these inputs.
And indeed what you can see here
is that the very first components,
create a significant
portion of the outcome,
and then every additional component,
every additional item that comes after it,
it's marginal contribution
to the total results,
it's significantly diminishing.
And in the end, it's almost zero.
So, this was maybe a bit theoretical.
So let's make it practical,
where is this really applied to practice?
Where does this really exist?
In our couple of examples from Wikipedia,
for instance, in the Wealth Distribution.
So for many countries, the 80/20 Rule,
more or less is indicative
of the Wealth Distribution
of the population.
So the wealthiest, the 20% of the people
own 80% of the total
wealth of the company.
Another application,
the Healthcare systems.
So, typically 20% of the patients
create 80% of the cost
of the healthcare system.
In business, in my opinion
say it's 20% of the products
creating 80% of the revenue.
And production, 20% of the parts
creating 80% of the
problem of the defaults.
Or in buying, 20% of all your suppliers
are responsible for 80%
of your cost baseline.
So these were just some examples
that are found on Wikipedia
and other places in the internet.
Of course, this is never
precisely exactly the case,
it just gives a rough indication.
But at least personally,
I find it really fascinating to see
that this is a relationship
that you really see often,
when you observe things
in the business world,
or in other areas of your daily life.
So, how can you apply this 80/20 Principle
in your work as a consultant?
Also as an employee working
in a certain business function
if you just want to understand
your business a bit better?
Because indeed this Pareto Analysis
is an analysis that you can do
in many many different
types of circumstances.
It's usually possible to
complete it with very basic data.
And it at least provides
one angle, one perspective
at the structure of the business,
how certain things are working
together and are interlinked.
So let me just share you one example.
I was working in a sales project.
And we're asking ourselves
how can we serve our customers
in a more cost-effective way?
So one of the first things that we did
is that we looked at the customer base
and we calculated the contribution margin
for each individual customer.
So we were asking ourselves
how much does the company earned
with each of these individual customers?
And then we ordered the customers
from the highest to the
lowest contribution margin.
And then we created the cumulate curve.
And of course, no big surprise,
it was a Pareto relationship.
Meaning that roughly the 20%
of the most profitable customers
contributed to 80% of the profits.
And then actually in the end,
the curve even went down,
because there were a couple of customers
which had a negative contribution margin.
So if you took the product margin
that was earned by selling
certain products to them,
and you subtracted
what the sales organization
was costing you.
So the cost to serve,
to actually serve these customers
and some of them were negative.
And this was a great discussion starter,
with the head of sales
talking about how can
we further prioritize
these largest most important customers?
What ways can we think of
to reduce the cost of sales
for the longterm?
For the end of this whole curve?
Where at the moment we're
actually even losing money.
Also did a couple of purchasing projects.
And here this is one of the first
standard analysis as well.
So looking at the supplier base,
and you're asking yourself,
how was the spend of the company
distributed among the suppliers?
And again, often you also
see this strong concentration
often spend with a couple of suppliers
and then this big long tail
and you're often again, the question is,
how can we optimize these?
Can we consolidate some of
the spend of the suppliers
in the long tail, with larger suppliers
to simplify the organization
and potentially also get volume discounts.
Next example, a project
where we looked into the
product portfolio of a company.
Again, same thing Pareto analysis.
You notice that a small
share of the products
create the vast majority of the revenue.
And the question then is what can we do
with the long tail?
Now, of course, do not
be misunderstood here.
This Pareto analysis is a very basic tool,
it's very quick and easy to
do it in the very beginning.
This will of course not
be the major insight
of such a project.
This will not be the end of it all.
But it's often a good effect
to first starting point
to get for yourself also.
Good understanding of how
this business is structured,
and potentially it can also
spark some first discussions
with your client
counterparts or colleagues
about certain topics,
that you now further want
to look into your project.
But before we jump into it,
I want to introduce you to
the sponsor of today's video.
And this sponsor is Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people.
You can explore new skills.
Deepen your passions and
get lost in creativity.
There are classes on marketing,
personal branding, presentations
skills, and many more.
All of these are topics
that are highly applicable
to a career in consulting,
banking, or corporate.
And the best thing
is that I made a slide
writing class for Skillshare,
so you can access and enjoy
it as a Skillshare member.
Personally, I recently took the class
Productivity Masterclass,
Principles and tools
to Boost Your Productivity
from the fellow YouTube, Ali Abdaal.
It's a great class that taught me
many new aspects of productivity.
And I very much enjoyed
to how you applied the Pareto Principle
or the 80/20 Rule to productivity.
Classes on Skillshare are
specifically created for learning.
There are no ads.
They're always launching
new premium classes
so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your
creativity takes you.
And the best thing is that
it's less than $10 a month
with an annual subscription.
Skillshare created a special offer
for subscribers of this
channel Firm Learning.
And so the first thousand
subscribers of me,
that click on this Skillshare
link in the video description
will get a free trial of the
Skillshare premium membership.
I hope this helps you to
explore your creativity,
check it out link in
the video description.
So, now let's look at the other way.
How the 80/20 Rule
is often used in consulting
in similar industries.
And this is for the internal
organization of work
for the prioritization of the team.
Also the time management, if you like.
And here the basic idea is,
that as with all the other things,
often 20% of the effort
of the work of a team
leads to 80% of the outcome.
And this of course, the
other way round means
that the last 20% of output,
the last 20% of polishing something,
takes 80% of the whole time.
So here the basic question
is, is this really necessary?
Is this really required?
And of course, your the meme behavior
of a consulting partner is
to walk into the team room
and say something like,
"Hey, let's be 80/20."
But then he/she proposes
a super detailed analysis
which would take the whole team
weeks and month as really to complete,
with no understanding at all,
what is really absolutely required.
And what is just a nice add on.
So, often it's always
a little bit of a joke.
Let's be 80/20 because unfortunately
or for whatever reason,
many many things,
many analysis that
consultants do, are not 80/20.
But there's often the big push
to be extremely diligent,
to be extremely detailed.
And of course that might
be good reasons for that,
but still the whole idea is important,
and does afterward also play
a big role in consulting.
And it happens all the time
that for instance, as a new team
joining a new client for a new project,
there might be a business
with different business units,
five business units, for instance.
But then you might decide
to only look into the biggest
two or three business units.
And actually you might have lots of ideas,
lots of improvement potential
for business unit four and five.
But these business units are so small.
Even if you improve their profit by 20%,
it's just such a little part
of the overall profit baseline
for the company,
that the impact would
just not be good enough.
And you would be much better off,
if we really would focus on the
larger three business units.
And of course, considerations like that,
breakdown up to the activities
of really the most junior
people in the team room.
So you might be a business analyst,
you're working on an analysis.
And you get some data from the client
and you do an analysis,
but then you realize that
certain pieces are missing.
The client did not provide the full data
of certain products,
certain business units,
whatever certain data
points are still not there.
And you of course, the
natural inclination is that,
yes, you need this.
You might need to spend another week
to talk to another person
who can provide you
with this data as well.
With many many similar tasks
it's very easy to invest a lot of time
into really getting
something from 90% to 100%.
And you are just so important
to always have the bigger picture in mind.
Is this really helping you
to answer the questions
that you want to answer?
Or, aren't 80% or 90% of the information
not good enough to actually
get exactly these answers?
Is this additional 10-20%
of results really required?
Does this even help you at all?
So, if you'd like to
simplify it in the end
being 80/20 means to be pragmatic.
To not over-complicate things.
To realize and understand
when what you have is just
good enough for what you need.
Or to use another meme coinciding phrase.
The opposite of being
80/20 is to boil the ocean,
but to get really everything done,
to put as much energy into something
that you will be able to
really boil the ocean.
So, ladies and gents, let's
not boil the ocean please,
but let's be a bit more 80/20 here.
- So, hope you found this
interesting and insightful.
Now I'd love to hear from you.
Let me know in the comments
what are your experiences
with the 80/20 Principle?
What is your favorite
application of the principle?
I'd love to hear that.
So as always, if you liked the video,
if you took any value out of it at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel,
to stay up to date on all my content.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
In addition to that, feel free
to follow me on Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning.
I have also an email is sign
up in the video description.
And I wanna end by saying,
thanks to all the
members of firm learning.
You're really making a big
contribution to the channel.
And of course, I also want to
say thank you to Skillshare,
the sponsor of this video.
So, if you want to benefit
from this free Skillshare trial,
check out the link in
the video description.
So see you next week.
Very much looking forward to next video,
to talking to you again next Saturday.
So until then, bye-bye.
My name is Heinrich Rusche,
this is Firm Learning, cheers.